SPEAKER: When it comes
to cost optimization,
you want to make sure that
you're running your workloads
as efficiently as possible.
Of course, that definitely
means not paying for resources
that you're not using.
Today, we'll talk about Google
Kubernetes Engine's autoscaling
and go over some tips.
Let's go beyond your GKE bill.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One major advantage
of Kubernetes
is how it was built
with scaling in mind.
And GKE adds even
more options to scale.
It can work pretty well
without much configuration,
but there's a lot
of cost optimization
potential by going deeper.
In the last video,
we talked a lot
about how to choose
the right machine type.
As always, it really depends
on knowing your application's
resource needs.
And that's just as important
for configuring autoscaling.
I'll start with an introduction
to autoscaling, and then dive
deep into horizontal
and vertical autoscaling
for your workloads.
Starting with the basics,
autoscaling is really
all about two things--
getting additional resources
when demand increases
and shutting down or
removing resources
when demand decreases.
By setting autoscaling
up efficiently
and specific to your
workload, you'll
be able to minimize
waste and cost.
In order to understand how you
should configure autoscaling,
let's simplify everything into
workloads and infrastructure.
Workloads are made up of
pods, which are running
containerized applications.
Infrastructure is
made up of nodes,
which are responsible
for the actual resources,
like computing
capacity and memory.
For each of these, there's
also two ways to scale--
horizontally or vertically.
Horizontal scaling is done
by adding more pods or nodes.
If there's a lot of
demand coming in,
the autoscaler can try to
increase the number of pods
or nodes to handle it.
Vertical scaling is done by
making pods or nodes bigger.
When demand increases,
a larger pod or node
may be able to reduce the
burden by handling more.
With those basics,
let's talk about how
GKE handles autoscaling.
Let's start with the
workload and pod size
by looking at the aptly named
horizontal pod autoscaler
and vertical pod autoscaler.
For horizontal
scaling, you'll need
a metric that represents
the demand on your workload,
such as CPU utilization
or requests per second.
With that target, the
horizontal pod autoscaler
can try to add pods to get your
workload back to your desired
state.
Adding pods should mean that
the work is spread out evenly,
and a metric like
average CPU utilization
would go down across your pods.
Similarly, if there's
not much demand,
the autoscaler can
remove pods, which
is great for saving on costs.
When using a horizontal
pod autoscaler,
remember that there
might be a lag
time depending on how long
it takes your container
to start up.
Setting the correct amount
of available metric space,
or buffer, requires knowing
how well you can handle spikes
in demand.
If the buffer is too small
and the pods take a long time
to spin up, your app
might get overloaded.
On the other hand,
too large of a buffer
can lead to wasted
resources and extra costs.
So a few things to keep in mind.
Understand what capacity
might be needed for a spike,
and set your buffer accordingly.
Do what you can to have your
pods spin up quickly and shut
down efficiently.
Make sure to set up
the right readiness
and live probes so GKE can
make the best decisions.
And remember to make sure
that your metric server
is always up and running.
I know we haven't talked
about what some of these
mean, but keep them
in mind, and we'll
come back to these
when we dive deeper
into optimizing
your applications.
So that's horizontal
pod autoscaling.
Now, let's look at
vertical pod autoscaling.
Rather than adding
additional pod replicas,
here, the pods
actually get recreated
with more or less
resources, depending
on CPU and memory usage.
Remember that too few resources
can overload your apps
and too many resources will mean
that you're paying for things
that you're not using.
Vertical pod autoscaling
works to solve this.
It has three modes--
off, initial, and auto.
When it's off, no
autoscaling actually happens,
but the autoscaler is
looking at your pods
and creating recommendations
based on usage
that you can inspect, which also
happens in the other two modes.
If it's set to initial,
those recommendations
will be used to create resized
pods as they're needed.
After creating a pod at
the recommended size,
based on those recommendations,
it won't change the pod size
afterward.
If the autoscaler
is set to auto,
those recommendations will be
used to regularly resize pods
by deleting them and recreating
them with the adjusted amounts.
In general, you should make sure
that vertical pod autoscaling
is off for at least a
day, or ideally a week,
in order to collect
recommendation data.
Then, you can switch to initial
or auto based on your needs,
or you can just keep it off
and review the recommendations
to manually adjust your pods.
Here's some things
to keep in mind.
If you're looking to
handle sudden spikes,
use horizontal pod
autoscaling instead.
Vertical pod autoscaling
can take a bit longer
than horizontal since it
can grow the number of pods
without taking any offline.
Make sure that your app
can actually benefit
from additional resources.
If it's single-threaded
or limited
by workers, rather
than resources,
vertical pod autoscaling
might not help at all.
Set minimums and maximums
and avoid any large changes,
since abrupt changes can
require new deployments.
Don't forget to keep your
metric server healthy.
Note auto-provisioning,
which we'll
talk more about
in the next video,
can help by creating new
nodes that can better
fit your resized pods.
And if you're using auto,
make sure that your workload
can handle restarts.
Also, you'll want to
choose a pod disruption
budget to control the number
of changes happening at once.
You can use both horizontal
and vertical pod autoscaling
at the same time, but
there's a few things
that you need to
be careful about.
First of all, you shouldn't
use them on the same resource,
like CPU or memory.
Both autoscalers are trying
to react to changes in demand
on that same metric,
and that could
cause overlapping problems.
But you can always keep
vertical pod autoscaler
in off mode to get
recommendations
without any changes
actually being made,
along with using
horizontal pod autoscaling,
so your app can
scale horizontally
based on CPU utilization
while you can make decisions
based on those vertical pod
autoscaling recommendations.
Or, you can use a custom metric
for the horizontal autoscaler,
like requests per second.
In addition, you should
ensure that your deployments
are receiving
enough traffic when
both autoscalers are enabled.
That way, the vertical
part autoscaler
can get accurate data for
creating recommendations.
As always, it depends
on your workload
to know whether you should
use horizontal, vertical,
or both pod autoscalers.
But we're not stopping there.
On the next video, we'll cover
the cluster autoscaler and node
auto-provisioning.
Remember to check out the
link in the description
for the full guide on
GKE cost optimization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]